L
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THE DEFENSE HAS RESTED IN THE
TRIAL OF A HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN LAWYER ACCUSED OF LYING
TO THE FBI ABOUT THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA PROBE.
MICHAEL SUSSMANN CHOSE NOT TO
TESTIFY IN HIS OWN DEFENSE.
CORRESPONDENT DAVID SPUNT IS
OUTSIDE THE FEDERAL COURTHOUSE
HERE IN WASHINGTON AS HE HAS
BEEN EVERY NIGHT TO TELL US
WHERE THINGS STAND TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, DAVID.
>> BRET, TWO MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS
IN COURT TODAY.
THE FIRST WE KNOW THAT CLOSING
ARGUMENTS WILL KICK OUT
TOMORROW.
THE SECOND ONE IS THE FACT THAT
MICHAEL SUSSMANN, DESPITE WHAT
SOME PEOPLE THOUGHT HE MAY, HE
ENDED UP NOT TESTIFYING.
IT WAS THE FIRST TIME, BRET,
THAT WE HEARD FROM MICHAEL
SUSSMANN DIRECTLY IN COURT AS HE
STOOD BEFORE THE JUDGE,
CHRISTOPHER COOPER, AND
CONFIRMED TO THE JUDGE THAT HE
WOULD NOT TESTIFY TO DEFEND
HIMSELF ON THE STAND.
SUSSMANN IS CHARGED WITH LYING
TO THE FBI, SPECIFICALLY THEN
FBI GENERAL COUNSEL JAMES BAKER.
WHEN HE CAME TO BAKER IN
DECEMBER 2016 AND SAID HE HAD
INFORMATION LINKING THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION TO A RUSSIAN BANK
WITH KREMLIN TIES VIA A COMPUTER
SERVER.
JOHN DURHAM, THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
SAYS THE ACTUAL LIE IS WHEN
SUSSMANN TOLD BAKER HE WAS
DELIVERING THE INFORMATION ON
HIS OWN NOT ON BEHALF OF ANY
CLIENTS.
DURHAM ARGUES THAT SUCCESS
SUSSMANN WENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND SAYS THAT
BILLING EVIDENCE HE SHOWED
JURORS PROVES IT SUSSMANN'S TEAM
SAYS HE DID NOTHING WRONG AND
HAS HAD A LONG WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FBI AND
WOULD NEVER LIE TO THE BUREAU.
JUDGE COOPER TODAY, BRET, READ
INSTRUCTIONS TO JURORS.
TOLD THEM TO SEVERAL QUESTIONS
CHIEFLY WAS MICHAEL SUSSMANN'S
STATEMENT FALSE, FICTITIOUS AND
MATERIAL TO THE INVESTIGATION
AND ALSO DID MICHAEL SUSSMANN
ACT KNOWINGLY OR WILLFULLY WITH
THE INTENTION TO BREAK THE LAW
IN THE FINAL QUESTION WAS THE
STATEMENT MADE IN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT, IN THIS
CASE THE FBI?
IF JURORS BELIEVE THE GOVERNMENT
PROVED ITS CASE YARD, THEY ARE
INSTRUCTED TO FIND MICHAEL
SUSSMANN GUILTY.
AFTER CLOSING ARGUMENTS
TOMORROW, DELIBERATIONS WILL
LIKELY BEGIN TUESDAY AFTER THE
LONG WEEKEND AND, BRET, IF COLOR
FROM THE COURTROOMED TO, I HAVE
NOTICED THIS AND I HAVE NOTICED
THIS EVERY DAY SPECIAL COUNSEL
JOHN DURHAM IS ACTIVELY INVOLVED
IN THIS CASE.
HE SITS AT THE TABLE WITH HIS
ATTORNEYS.
HE TAKES NOTES, PASSES NOTES.
EVEN TODAY HE CROSSED OVER TO
THE AISLE TO MAKE SMALLTALK WITH
MICHAEL SUSSMANN'S DEFENSE TEAM
AS MICHAEL SUSSMANN JUST SAT
STOICALLY